on may first 2012 phone courage attended
to press roundtable interview with
director Patricia Reagan for the film
girl in progress this audio is from that
interview session for more information
on girl in progress please visit girl in
progress movie.com well with under the
same moon and this movie I see kind of a
nice little trend go in other words
every director has a trademark type of
film that they make so do you feel like
that's happening with you now I like to
yes I I think it's different and it has
a lot of similarities you know because
now it's still a mom and a kid right but
they're they're living in the same house
but they're separated so in a way that's
similar to only the same woman how are
we going to get these two together if I
have a trademark is probably that I like
family and I like people discovering the
goodness and characters and helping them
come together I like that it's I think I
heard you know because we've been
screaming little bit women of all ages
and they're really responding to to that
connection and the movie sound provoking
communication between moms and daughters
that's a really good thing that
discovering the goodness in characters
just up Ava had an interesting thing to
say about how she did the things about
race she didn't like and we very rarely
hear two factors judge their character
soon as I say that that's a high state
of a play-doh surprise but they made me
wonder how far you feel like you can
push
people because you do meet her as a
pretty bad mother and I'm not a Norfolk
example of nurturing person and and you
weren't how far can you push the
audience before you draw them back in to
be honored no I think you know I think a
magnetic great job in bringing the
humanity of the character because she's
terribly flawed as a mom but she's also
very likable and I think we see her
making mistakes but we also understand
that she's trying to go her best she was
a young mom herself you know in the
character got pregnant when she was 17
and now she has a teen daughter and she
doesn't know how to be a mom so I think
the key for me was to understand the
character from that other side you know
I brought that little back story there
you know when we understand that she was
17 when she had she was kicked out from
out so she's trying to provide she's has
two jobs killing herself and she's
neglecting her daughter emotionally I
guess you know and that's what she comes
to learn but it's a fine line and I
think she did a terrific job allowing us
to like her despite the fact that we're
seeing her make so many mistakes well
that was interesting is there was a line
in there about you know for her
character to put the wives in the
restaurant hater oh and I should have
the big old but you know I actually the
scene continues like should I put this
on yeah you know I feel like it was you
know she's been called upon to use a lot
of her charm in the bigger studio movies
but what made you see that that deeper
quality that where her charm was going
to sort of keep that character viable
for the audience but she was also going
to dig into the more dramatic elements I
think she wanted to do this very about
she read this character and she saw me
character when she could really show
that other side of her and she she's
such a beautiful glamorous girl and she
knows that about herself and she was
very conscious of having herself real
everything a moment even more her than
me she knew that she had to keep her
looks you know she's a working plan girl
she has two jobs she doesn't have time
and and she said we need to be very
careful though don't don't put anything
that you know it's going to strike that
other other character that I played you
know this is a real girl she would ask
me to find my yes you know she just kept
it real i think that's allowing women
females to connect with this character
because it's not you know the glamorous
go if the working girl that's really
just trying what was your hardest the
one that you did you can I think we're
on the same way you can't have a feeling
about that certain see more when I get
that phone over a yeah because this
which was related or anything definitely
the boolean see you know I have I work
with Raini Rodriguez and she's in the
middle of the cafeteria right she's it's
all complete and and this girl is gonna
be on her all this powerful faint I knew
it was going to be very hard I her
father was there she was there and we're
talking real human beings here we're not
you know it's a real girl and I was
going to put her through that moment
even if he's acting she's gonna leave
that moment so I kept their the mean
girl I said you know not really laid it
out too we were really going to shoot
that moment you know so I wouldn't
expose her so much but rainy so graceful
and so self-confident it's so beautiful
inside and out that she just made it
very easy for me but that was a hard one
for me what was about Ciara
got you to get her into the role and her
chemistry with anyone well first of all
it's your have never acted in a movie so
I didn't have that actor ranked you know
she didn't have the chops you didn't
have the training but at she sent me a
tape when she was 11 years old singing
at the Apollo Theater like Aretha
Franklin and having everybody bring me
on and I thought oh my god this little
girl you know the courage this is I see
that for sure I don't know if she can
lag but she can definitely put on a show
and and I thought you know I want to
choose a girl that I want to see for two
hours that I want to fall in love for
two hours and took it upon myself to
help her through you know this very
complex performance but I knew I had a
girl that I just wanted to watch their
clothes that's what I think makes a
difference between just a good actor and
a star how do you strike that balance
between hitting those universal themes
that anybody can relate to and then also
tell me stories as specific details for
the American latina I concentrate first
on for most of you saying they're human
experience and in this case a female
experience and giving them you know just
very round with characters trades flaws
very Church and and then I don't push
the lateen aspect because I am latina so
it just comes out really natural when
you go into the details of what they eat
and what they hear that's when the
culture the richness of the culture
comes in and makes it very specific but
the experience is the human experience
is the female experience so I always
thought this this a movie for the
general audience it's for for females of
all ages and then they just happen to be
Latinas and I like that I said it in
Seattle and now in a border state
because we're you so used to the latinas
in the words these are just two American
also you know they're over there there's
living there like they're struggling
like like so many others so you could
really be about any culture and race but
their specific things and I like when
the daughter says don't be such an
immigrant like there's that tension
between and then is that Banda music
they play at the party it's like Banda
which you never hear in in a lot of
films so what was your take on that and
building all of that together I know
what these households are like and I
know what they hear and so I always like
to incorporate for example music into
the movies not just added on later on
the green incorporated and since you
know this was a Mexican immigrant
mission impossible so in his house
they're teasing cabana and in fact I
have the biggest right now the biggest
star like the biggest thing or that's
the guise of thingy he's huge he's like
super stock and I want him to play an
immigrant you know the next morning he's
you know interesting his work you know
the uniform going to work in starbucks
yeah that's that's a reality i like that
the movies in a way to a reflection of
our society boobies normally are
hispanic all Hispanic Hollywood on Holly
what these were combining you know the
the Hollywood cars were they with the
Latin cast into one movie because that's
just how we live today you always get
managed to hit the biggest of the big
latino stars in your movie so are you
kind of like the lady mouth to cuddle
old mats and they said we mess it up
because you know opinion that basically
place Mission Impossible is the biggest
larger City comedian of all times from
Latin America and I gave him his first
femoral and his first dramatic role his
first time in Hollywood and he did a
very good job I mean he did an excellent
job pass as that guy in under the same
old and studio executives asking me you
know he could do comedy he said real
good Adam he could do committee the
comedian you know they
notice that so I brought him back I
think he is very charismatic and
certainly helpful to bring us that all
their audience Phil yeah I think um I
don't know it seems to me that more
police have been portrayed as with boys
it's more of a voice being boy nerd
boring this or that but it's interesting
and I think it's good awareness for
girls because I think young teenage
girls have such a self-esteem issues
right and you've been catering is that
it was you know the ruling subject
matter it's at the heart of unsee that
story you know her coming-of-age is
realizing what you know how words can
affect people and how ruling can can
hurt someone's life so deeply you know
we see that all the time in society so
I'd like that that's at the heart her
own coming-of-age story this is it's
it's a movie where all the characters
are going through changes through
coming-of-age moments who did you look
at besides Eva Mendes are squishy the
only one what was your spectrum of
actresses for that wrong well there's
not a long face you know there's exactly
because the the studio executives they
want someone that means something in
Hollywood right so there's not too many
out there but I think in kc jennifer
lopez could be Jennifer Ryan could be
sama sama although some ice Mexican so
you know we wanted an American girl with
that you know American accent she's just
searching her if she hadn't signed on
would it have been made like I think I
think it was a very great character for
any of those girls so if it wasn't ever
hopefully someone else would have come
on board thankfully I didn't move e that
was very successful that me smile on
that so it showed that I really care
about actors and I love performances and
I I work with them to give them good
moments her comedic timing is so awesome
and it's like did you did you have to
adjust that at all or do we you I mean
she's just very good right you know I
discovered a lot about Emma in the
process because we don't get to audition
this girl you know you can ask them and
she you know I saw every movie she had
done so I can learn about her book also
the roles were you know in a way similar
she was very glam very beautiful playing
that role but she hadn't I hadn't seen
her real you know like really pretty you
no doubt worth working-class girl and I
was so blessed that she she has a great
commit she's very funny and she also has
you know the drama she's she's a very
very good actress another night another
both race and not see that have to deal
with his understand the consequences of
your choices and I felt that the bedroom
scene with this apparent that they did a
cycle in fact there's a lot of comedy in
it it's also i mean the daddy and me was
saying get up get out of don't do that
and and so i thought there was a scene
that required a lot of again fine
tightrope walking talk a bit about that
did you try a different ways or have it
you know i was at her pants were there
you know that's also about another one
the very tricky seen you know and she
said young girl she hasn't had any of
these experiences so I was very
conscious and very careful of not
exploiting the girl not exploiting what
I know works out there in the mania
which is could be you know more sexual
more out there showing more we don't
need that it's all about what's really
happening underneath them so I made you
know she takes her other we're under the
covers and it just I think if you work
from your hearty just it just all
happened so one thing I'm be scoring is
that the movies being embraced by
families and I think it has to do with
the way we feel all right
with very strong softeners were in a
very elegant where it's all away because
we don't need to talk to say what we
need to say you say I wanted the movie
to be seen my kids you know when I got
the script at the beginning or sandhar
rated script and I thought I don't want
to make a movie that girls can watch is
this a movie about girls I want girls to
be able to watch it so I adjusted
everything to be able to open it for
them so you said you were looking
specifically for an American who would
have the American accent so do you think
the movie will play in spanish-speaking
country I'm hoping you know I think this
is a this is a tricky movie it's not
clear you know because we think is
latina because yes latina it's very
general but you know we have a haenyeo
money Spinoza who are huge mexican and
latin american star so that will help us
you know put it out there and it's
really about the female experience I
think I think single moms are out there
everywhere in every society and the
struggles that single moms face about
you know young pregnancy is present in
all members you know of communities in
our society and the movies also you know
tackling that very important subject
matter so I'm hoping that it please
everywhere we do well here it will play
more and I think we're lucky we got the
Mother's Day weekend exact it's a movie
that speaks to females to moms and
daughters and I'm hoping that that's
their their movie of choice that we get
a weekend yeah don't see the Avenger yet
I love you indistinct is